a beaucoup pas géré une ville sous
occupation russe des administrés en exil
et une centrale nucléaire comme une épée
de Damoclès elle est la priorité du
renseignement ukrainien qui estime que
Moscou est prêt à y déclencher un
accident pour figer le front
la situation est tendue sur le site
jusqu'à quel point les occupants
donneront la possibilité aux employés
d'assurer la sécurité du lieu car les
soldats y vivent ils dorment et ont une
base militaire avec des munitions sur
place personne ne sait quel ordre ils
vont en recevoir et qu'elles en seront
les conséquences on ne peut qu'espérer
que ça
ce qui l'inquiète avant tout c'est le
sort des employés Ukrainiens qui ont
gardé leur poste
la pression sur eux est forte les appels
qu'on reçoit de la zone occupée nous
disent tous que la pression s'accroît
une partie des employés va travailler
environ 2500 personnes la majorité
d'entre eux doivent désormais assigner
des contrats sous la pression avec
rosatum l'entreprise russe mobile
car ils ne peuvent pas les remplacer
il a organisé ce centre pour que les
exilés des nergoda puissent trouver de
l'aide ici la plupart des hommes sont
d'anciens techniciens de la centrale
moi je travaillais comme chef d'équipe
département des turbines je me sens
assez anxieux parce que je sais comment
ces équipements fonctionnent et qu'une
interférence peut déboucher sur de
graves problèmes
[Musique]
comment ne pas s'inquiéter je m'inquiète
parce que c'est ma ville il y a déjà
assez de problèmes comme ça mais je fais
confiance aux employés je connais
beaucoup d'entre eux ils se battront car
ils vivent là mais avec ses dents qui
tiennent le site pardonner l'expression
tout est possible
la destruction du barrage de Nova
carrosca ne les rassure pas pour eux
c'est inimaginable mais c'est ainsi leur
centrale est devenue une arme dans
l'arsenal russe en Ukraine